hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrolra.l
2-3.11.2 scan for vulnerabilities and
organizational systems and applications
periodically and when new
vulnerabilities affecting those systems
and applications are identified
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
defarge and nist SP 10171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it okay so this control is pretty easy
to comply with if you have the right
antivirus or endpoint management system
in place basically to break this down
you need antivirus or vulnerability scan
which is both scheduled and then
typically one that will also activate on
demand typically an event driven
activation such as a new file is
downloaded or a new device is attached
to the system such as a USB device thumb
drive portable hard drive that kind of
thing or upon file execution which
exhibits unexpected or specifically
malicious behavior
now let's dive into the assessment
points learn specifically what the
assessors want to see on this one uh
several assessment points so and again
the neat thing is they're sort of
describing how the antivirus needs to
function uh so first determine if the
frequency to scan for vulnerabilities
and organizational systems and
applications is defined uh if we were to
give an answer we might say hey
frequency is definitely defined within
the antivirus program or the endpoint
management system or even maybe the
firewall uh by the IT team the IT team
sets that frequency determine if
vulnerability scans are performed on
organizational systems with the defined
frequency so determine if they're
actually done again Implement and verify
by the IT team evidence exists within
the log files or the anti-virus files or
anything like that determinant
vulnerability scans are performed on
applications with the defined frequency
so now we're specific on applications
again we would just say hey this is
verified by the IT team they get reports
on the antivirus system or the endpoint
management system to prove that it is
actually happening next one is determine
if vulnerability scans are performed on
or organizational systems when new
vulnerabilities are identified
uh this is implemented verified by the
IT team evidence exists within the SCCM
uh so again uh just another example you
could use SCCM it's just sort of an
example we give uh final one is
determine if vulnerability scans are
performed on applications when new
vulnerabilities are identified so
basically is it automatic Implement and
verified by the IT team again the
evidence exists within the log files and
history of the anti-virus or endpoint
management solution
uh and hey if you have questions about
what's the best antivirus to make to use
what the best endpoint is you know what
we can probably give you a little bit of
guidance because we do that every day we
manage technology for literally uh tens
of thousands of endpoints and hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of companies
uh we love taking care of the technology
management aspect of uh of things for
defense contractors along with
compliance we can definitely help you to
find a good suitable endpoint management
solution uh and if you are like so many
of our clients who have had this defars
nist itar and cmmc compliance stuff
dropped into their laps like a seal on a
sunny day we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps great
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you you can visit CMC
compliance secrets.com or check out the
bio below for links that can allow you
to help get help right now if you love
the content we're putting out here for
you help us out with a big thumbs up on
that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance learns roll it out it's a
great way to stay in touch and to stay
up to date with what's going on in
compliance let's say next compliance tip
my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance I'll see you on
the next one
[Music]